WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY JEN
PSAKI COMING UP.
THE BIDEN BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ASKED FOR RESIGNATION FROM
APPOINTED BOARDS.
ONE MEMBER REFUSING TO RESIGN
MEGAN MOBBS AN APPOINTED MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF VISITORS AT WEST
POINT.
SHE IS ALSO A VETERAN OF THE WAR
IN AFGHANISTAN AND SHE IS AN
ADVOCATE FOR VETERANS AND
MILITARY FAMILIES.
MEGAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH US THIS MORNING.
CAN YOU JUST TELL US OFF THE
START HERE WHY ARE YOU REFUSING
TO RESIGN?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME ON.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE.
THE REASON WHY I'M REFUSING TO
RESIGN IT IS IMPERATIVE WE DO
NOT POLITICIZE OUR MILITARY
ACADEMIES.
WHEN I WAS FIRST APPOINTED TO
THE BOARD, THERE WERE FOUR OBAMA
APPOINTEE HOLDOVERS THAT WERE
THERE SERVING OUT THEIR
THREE-YEAR TERMS.
I WAS GRACIOUSLY WELCOMED,
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
AND THAT TYPE OF NONPARTISAN
ENGAGEMENT IS WHAT WE NEED IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW, THE ABILITY
TO COME TOGETHER, HAVE
DISCUSSIONS BRING DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES, HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY I'M NOT
GOING TO STEP DOWN.
>> SO WHY DO YOU THINK YOU WERE
ASKED TO RESIGN?
>> I THINK IT IS FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS.
THE ONLY WAY I CAN IMAGINE IS
BECAUSE OF THIS POLITICIZATION
OR THIS KIND OF WANTING TO
CAPTURE THIS AS BEING A
POLITICAL APPOINTED BOARD.
WHILE YOU ARE APPOINTED BY THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF, THE
PRESIDENT, WHO BY THEIR VERY
NATURE IS FROM A POLITICAL
PARTY, THIS ADVISORY BOARD IGTS
IS REMARKABLY NONPARTISAN, ONE
OF THE LAST PLACES IN AMERICA
WHERE THOSE THINGS ARE CHECKED
AT THE DOOR.
WHAT COMES FIRST IS THE HEALTH,
THE WELL BEING OF THE CADETS TO
MAKE SURE AT LEAST SPEAKING ACT
WEST POINT RIGHT NOW, TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE BEST POSSIBLE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME EXCELLENT
ARMY OFFICERS.
>> YOU KNOW, LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU SAY IT'S
NOT ABOUT POLITICIZING THE BOARD
AND YOU SAY THE PRESIDENT
SHOULDN'T POLITICIZE THE
MILITARY.
DIDN'T PRESIDENT TRUMP
POLITICIZE THE MILITARY?
>> I THINK THERE'S A LONG
HISTORY OF MANY PRESIDENTS
POLITICIZING THE MILITARY.
AND HONESTLY WHAT I REALLY WANT
TO SPEAK ABOUT, THOUGH, IS THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S DECISION TO DO
SO VERSUS DECISIONS MADE BY
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT IN THIS MOMENT
NOW TO ACCEPT WHAT'S HAPPENING
BECAUSE THIS HAS NOT BEEN
HAPPENED BEFORE.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED MOVE BY
A PRESIDENT TO DISSOLVE ALL
BOARDS, ALL APPOINTEES AND LABEL
THEM ALL AS BEING UNQUALIFIED.
>> OKAY.
SO, I WANT TO ASK YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU SAY
IT'S ABOUT FOCUSSING ON WHAT
BIDEN IS DOING, NOT WHAT TRUMP
IS DOING.
YOU OBVIOUSLY WERE AN ADVISER TO
THE CAMPAIGN, FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN,
WHEN IT CAME TO VETERAN AND
MILITARY FAMILY OUTREACH.
YOU HAVE RECENTLY BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT WHAT YOU TALK
ABOUT AND, LOOK, MANY PEOPLE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT AS THE MORAL
INJURY OF THE EVACUATIONS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
AS AN ADVISER TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, DID YOU ADVISE THEM OR
THE PRESIDENT ON THE MORAL
INJURY OF BASICALLY SCRAPPING
THE SIV PROGRAM THAT CONTRIBUTED
TO THE DIFFICULTIES THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN EVACUATING AFGHAN
ALLIES?
>> SO THAT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT
I WORKED ON.
IT WOULD BE VERY HARD FOR ME TO
SPEAK ON.
SOMETHING I'M OFTEN AN ADVOCATE
FOR IS MENTAL HEALTH FOR ALL OF
OUR VETERANS ACROSS
ADMINISTRATIONS AND SOMETHING I
THINK IS REMARKABLY AGAIN
BIPARTISAN AND NONPARTISAN
ENSURING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OUR VETERANS, MILITARY
AND OUR MILITARY FAMILIES ARE
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN A VARIETY
OF WAYS AND THIS INCLUDES AT THE
V.A. AND INCLUDES DURING THEIR
PERIOD OF SERVICE AND ALSO
DURING THEIR PERIOD OF BEING AT
THE ACADEMIES ENSURING WE'RE
TAKING PROPER AND APPROPRIATE
PRECAUTIONS TO MAKE SURE THOSE
NEEDS ARE ADDRESSED.
EVERY OPPORTUNITY I CAN SPEAK
ABOUT GETTING LEFT OF BANG AHEAD
OF ANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT
MIGHT OCCUR AS A RESULT OF
MILITARY SERVICE I'M A VERY
OUTSPOKEN ADVOCATE FOR THAT.
>> YEAH, LOOK, CERTAINLY NOT
TAKING AWAY FROM YOUR ADVOCACY
ON THAT WHERE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRANSITIONS FOR
MILITARY PERSONNEL AND JUST HOW
THAT CAN AFFECT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH.
YOU TALKED ABOUT A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT I THINK THERE'S
BROAD BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT ON
SAYING THAT, HEY, THESE ARE
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
YOU ALSO, THOUGH, YOU WERE AN
ADVISER TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND I DO WONDER IF, FOR
INSTANCE, ON THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE SEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST
YESTERDAY PRAISING OR NOT
PRAISING, REALLY PUSHING BACK ON
THE REMOVAL OF THIS ROBERT E.
LEE STATUE IN RICHMOND.
HE ACTUALLY REFERRED TO THE
FORMER CONFEDERATE GENERAL AS A
UNIFYING FORCE.
HE SAID IF ONLY WE HAD ROBERT E.
LEE TO COMMAND OUR TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN THAT DISASTER WOULD
HAVE ENDED IN A COMPLETE AND
TOTAL VICTORY MANY YEARS AGO.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT WE'RE
SUFFERING BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE GENIUS OF ROBERT E. LEE.
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE AS SOMEONE ON
THE BOARD OF VISITORS FOR WEST
POINT, YOU'RE WELL AWARE THAT
WEST POINT IS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO DO WITH ALL OF ITS
STUFF THAT'S NAMED AFTER ROBERT
E. LEE, LEE BARE RICKS THAT YOU
OR WHILE YOU WERE AT WEST POINT
ONE OF YOUR FELLOW CADETS MAY
HAVE ACTUALLY STAYED IN AS A
DORM.
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU SAY WHEN
YOU HEAR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SAYING THINGS LIKE THIS?
>> SO, WE SERVE AT THE CURRENT
PLEASURE OF THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT WHICH IS WHY HE'S ABLE
TO TERMINATE IN THE WAY THAT HE
DID.
SO MY FOCUS IS ENSURING THAT
WE'RE REPRESENTING THOSE VALUES
AND THOSE ETHICS WHEN WE COME TO
THE BOARD OF VISITORS AND MAKING
SURE AGAIN THOSE DECISIONS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE OUTSIDE
OF THE PURVIEW OF THE ADVISORY
BOARD.
WE'RE THERE TO PROVIDE INSIGHT
AROUND CURRICULUM, AROUND
DISCIPLINE, ABOUT FISCAL
EXPENDITURES AROUND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS.
SO WE'RE NOT NECESSARILY HAVING
DISCUSSIONS AROUND ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU JUST MENTIONED.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO SPEAK
ABOUT WHICH I THINK IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE DO BRING UP VERY
FREQUENTLY IS THE RISE OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
OUR MILITARY ACADEMIES AND IN
THE MILITARY BROADLY SPEAKING.
SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE FOCUSSED ON.
WE'RE FOCUSSING HOW WE CAN BEST
AND APPROPRIATELY MEET THE NEEDS
AND DEMANDS OF THE CADETS SO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING AREN'T THINGS THAT
HAPPEN AT THE ADVISORY BOARD.
>> DO YOU SEE HOW SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAVE
LOOKED AT HERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
MAYBE DON'T BELONG ON ADVISORY
BOARDS FOR SERVICE ACADEMIES,
FOR INSTANCE, FORMER KERNEL WHO
HAS ATTACKED THE ROLE OF WOMEN
IN CERTAIN MILITARY SITUATIONS?
OR HAS YOU KNOW ADVANCED
REPLACEMENT THEORY OR A FORMER
APPOINTEE WHO TRIED TO GET
ELECTION FRAUD INFORMATION TO
THE WHITE HOUSE FROM THE DOJ OR
PEOPLE WHO ENABLED THE BIG LIE
WHICH WAS REALLY THE IMPETUS FOR
MANY VETERANS AND EVEN ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS BREAKING
INTO CONGRESS.
DO YOU SEE A DISTINCTION HERE
BETWEEN SOME PEOPLE LIKE AN HR
McMASTER OR I'M SURE YOU WOULD
PUT YOURSELF IN THIS CATEGORY,
SOMEONE -- HE'S BEING HONORED As
A GRADUATE OF WEST POINT HERE
SOON.
DO YOU THINK THAT IT MAKES SENSE
THAT SOME OF THESE PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SCRAPPED BUT THAT
YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THEM?
HOW ARE YOU SEEING THIS?
>> SO, I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MYSELF.
I HAVEN'T MET THE INDIVIDUAL
THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING ACT.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A BOARD MEETING
SINCE THE ELECTION BECAUSE OF
THE SUSPENSION OF ALL THE BOARD.
SO I'VE NEVER WORKED ALONGSIDE
HIM OR KNOW HIM PERSONALLY.
SO AGAIN I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
MYSELF.
AND WHAT I CAN --
>> YOU MEGAN, MEGAN, LET'S NOT
DODGE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORK
ALONGSIDE SOMEONE TO KNOW THAT
THEY PROMOTE REPLACEMENT THEORY
OR THAT THEY ATTACK WOMEN BEING
IN MILITARY ROLES THAT MEN ARE
IN.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW THE
RECORD OF SOME OF THESE PEOPLE.
SO DO YOU THINK THAT IT MAKES
SENSE THAT SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
WOULD BE SCRAPPED?
>> SO I THINK IT MAKES SENSE
THAT ANY PRESIDENT CAN LOOK AT
THOSE THAT ARE APPOINTED AND
MAKE THE DECISION TO ASSESS ON
AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS.
I ABSOLUTELY THINK THE PRESIDENT
OBVIOUSLY HAS THAT ABILITY AND
THAT PURVIEW TO DO SO.
I THINK WHOLESALE SCRAPPING
EVERY APPOINTEE AND THROWING
KIND OF THE BABY OUT WITH THE
BATH WATER SETS A VERY DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT BECAUSE THIS SETS A
PRECEDENT FOR FUTURE
ADMINISTRATIONS TO DO THE EXACT
SAME THING.
AND IT PREVENTS THE ABILITY OF
WHAT I SPOKE ABOUT PREVIOUSLY
THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE
ROOTED IN VERY GOOD INTENTION
AND BELIEFS AROUND THE BEST WAY
TO SERVE CADETS CAN COME
TOGETHER AND CAN HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS AND HAVE THIS
DISCOURSE THAT'S DONE IN A
RESPECTFUL WAY.
AND BY DOING THIS, IT SETS THE
PRECEDENT THAT IN THE FUTURE
SOMEONE DISAGREES WITH SOMEONE
THEY CAN JUST LABEL THEM AS
BEING UNQUALIFIED OR JUST SCRAP
THEM WHOLESALE AND IT PREVENTS
THE ABILITY OF HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I THINK ARE
IMPERATIVE FOR OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> MEGAN, I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
LOOK, IT'S ONE WE VERY MUCH NEED
TO HAVE AS WE LOOK AT THE
CREDENTIALS OF ALL OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ON THESE
SERVICE ACADEMY ADVISORY BOARDS.
AND I APPRECIATE Y